Still struggling especially at night with a cough from the Aspergerus in the
right lung. I've nebulized, used a tincture, different essential oils used, applied
to the feet chest, and used any other suggestions. Well the best way to kill
something in your lung when it's a fungus in your lung like Aspergerus is
through a nebulizer. Trying different substances in the nebulizer would be my
choice. I would try different anti-fungal type nutrients that are liquid
that I'd put in the nebulizer using different concentrations and play with
that. I still think nebulizing is going to be the best way to get that out of
there. I will say that if I'm pretty sure this person is doing this, but
corticeps is a mushroom that is really essential for healing. The lungs make
sure you up the corticeps if you're taking corticeps make sure you bump that up as
well. I think we have corticeps mixed with some other herbs in a liquid that you
could nebulize that. Now that I think of it, that might be a good choice too. I
think it's a herbal throat or herbal dropper, lung dropper by close
defense that has corticeps in it. I would try that once when I would give that a
try, it's going to be a good choice.